because it's not just the training the
testing it's the injuries I mean you've
broken so many things yeah so I'm done
my scaphoid of them my ribs my
collarbone ruptured my spleen had that
taken out in Sydney actually in
Australia this is all from just training
and the guy in front me didn't see this
big metal like I don't know how you must
be blind but what have you broken here
that was my pelvis are you sure you can
cycle you've done it wait till he breaks
his pelvis though bate you break your
pelvis and then what happens what
carried on so basically I was stage 1 of
2013 tour so is that the top pelvis it's
not like it's not the the bit that
rotates when you're pedaling yeah you're
not sat on it so doctors were like oh
you're not gonna do any damage by riding
so if you can put up with the pain rock
on so it's kind of a bit like good you
know Wow but you had to do that for your
team because if you dropped out then
your team was screwed yeah I've been
training for that all you and I was part
of the team it's bit like in a football
team for instance you know you might be
a defenders you midfield and and it's
the same in a cycling team in a way you
know you have your jobs throughout the
day and I was part of that I'm the
training audio for that and I really
wanted to be a part of it so it was like
well I'm still here so I might as well
start tomorrow and try and do the team
you broken your pelvis
childbirth now
[Laughter]
[Music]
you